more than 70 Chinese military aircraft
have entered Taiwanese airspace over the
last 24 hours the Island's government
says this is the largest incursion to
date by China which claims sovereignty
over the self-governing territory
taiwan's defense Ministry said dozens of
fighter jets crossed the median line in
the Taiwan Strait which act as an
unofficial buffer zone Beijing said it
has conducted strike drills in response
to provocations from Taiwan and the
United States
and for more on that let's cross over to
DW correspondent Paul nwang in taiway
point why have these drills been
conducted now
so on Christmas Day the Chinese Army
conducted strike drills in the sea and
airspace around Taiwan according to
taiwan's military of National Defense 71
Chinese aircraft including fighter jets
and also drones enter taiwan's air
defense identification Zone China
claimed it was reacting to provoke
chance and collusion between the United
States and Taiwan because U.S just
passed a defense field uh defense bill
with a 10 billion US dollars in military
aids for Taiwan and China believes it's
severely severely affects peace and
stability across Taiwan Strait now tell
us more about this U.S defense
authorization law that boosts military
assistance for Taiwan
so U.S President Joe Biden on December
23rd signed into a law and 858 billion
U.S on defense policy Bill set to
increase security cooperation with
Taiwan the legislation authorized up to
10 billion US dollars in security
assistance over the next five years to
modernize taiwan's security capabilities
to deter aggression by Beijing the ACT
also you know affords Taiwan the same
treatments as major non-natal allies to
in receiving the priority to obtain
exist defense material from the U.S it
also said the holding joint military
exercise with Taiwan is important in
import improving combat redness and
Taiwan welcomes the the choice and also
said this show The Importance Washington
attached to Taiwan U.S ties and
strengthening the Island's security
now taiwan's defense Ministry said that
China's aim is to threaten and cow the
people of Taiwan how are people in
Taiwan feeling about all this
as we know that it was the largest
Chinese Air Force in inclusion to date
the scale is larger than live fires our
military exercise in August in response
to U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi's
visit to Taiwan although there was no
sense of alarm on the island people
still felt a steady increase increase in
Chinese pressure in recent years and the
office of taiwan's president said the
president's Taiwan will call a
high-level National Security meeting on
Tuesday morning to discuss reinforcing
the Island's civil defense system
followed by our press conference on the
news on new civil defense measures
there for us thank you very much